shortly in Australia they play in the
Australian summer as a nice look there
and fans sang right off the bat is what
it's like to be vying for a spot here on
an NBA roster never made it to fall camp
though well he doesn't charge us image
that time and Ben just made being along
the baseline and then here's the nice
little breakdown little pitter pat
crossover right to the bucket for the
easy two
and here's Simmons coming up with
eternal good instincts see right there
no one's playing them well let me free
up this opportunity for myself gets it
back off the boards finds a streaky
Markel along the baseline that's his
smart basketball finds a streaky marquel
along the baseline that's his smart
basketball per game tonight and on yep
he is taking a heart with Brett Brown
said before the game that shop with
those changes as
necessary Simmons beautiful rapper Adil
Amir Johnson Ben Simmons has been
remarkable as a set up guy here in the
first quarter you can't do much when Ben
gets the ball that deep into the post
into the painted area sees head is up
looking for a passer finds a mere Barlow
late a lot more to be confident about I
think Ben right now I'm not looking for
a sophomore dig boy you're just talking
about I'm cute turkey with Rance they're
gonna keep calling you and get you get
to suspend adulthood in real life for
one more years JJ why would you say
though rights to your averaging about 23
again Redick getting a look that's for a
three and JJ Redick whether starting are
coming off the bench still the same guy
Turkey with Rance they're gonna keep
calling you and get you get to suspend
adulthood it real
on the city the Thunder playing the
starters a lot of minutes a night hands
Simmons continues his gorgeous passing
here in the first half blinded Eric
Verdeans ooh now you bring up an
interesting point is indeed losses and
hits
well on the city the Thunder playing the
starters a lot of minutes a night Hannah
Simmons continues is gorgeous passing
here in the first half would look yeah
by charge inside for Simmons second time
on able to finish at Duncan 10th
darkness arts
would look yeah by charge inside for
Simmons second time on having a finish
at Duncan tent
Carlos arts we have tens players in your
MPA and that's something with super
Prado so we're getting people to know
about Australia through flying in the
NBA we want to come here and see where
we should into the structure and how for
us winning of courses as professionals
will do the big realistic and then we'll
play best of three semifinal justify
final
over six months period Mike muscala
that's what he did